أطلق على الركود بعد الأزمة المالية لعام 2008
لقب جلسة
الرجال لأن الكثير من الرجال تم تسريحهم من
وظائف البناء والتصنيع هذه المرة كانت أكثر
من جلسة في أبريل ومايو وكان
معدل البطالة للنساء أعلى مما
كان عليه بالنسبة للرجال.  ارتفاع مذهل في
معدلات البطالة في وقت سابق من هذا العام ،
بل والأسوأ بالنسبة للنساء ذوات البشرة الملونة والنساء من
أصل إسباني ، يرجع السبب في ذلك إلى أن النساء تميل
إلى العمل في القطاعات الأكثر ضعفًا
في المراحل الأولى من إغلاق
المطاعم وصالونات تصفيف الشعر في مجال
الرعاية الصحية الآن حتى مع بدء الأعمال التجارية
إعادة فتح العديد من القطاعات التي تهيمن عليها النساء قد
لا يعيد توظيف أو استبدال كل تلك الوظائف
المفقودة من هذا التحليل الوبائي من
الاقتصاديين في سيتي جروب ويظهر مع
خروج النساء من القوى العاملة ، فهذا يعني
انخفاضًا بقيمة تريليون دولار في النمو العالمي
قد يضر بالانتعاش في الوقت
الذي تستمر فيه عمليات التسريح.  تقدم آلاف الآلاف
منهم الأسبوع الماضي من شركة Erica للياقة البدنية التي تعمل على مدار 24 ساعة
بطلب إفلاس وأغلقت أكثر
من مائة صالة ألعاب رياضية قامت AT&T المملوكة لشبكة
CNN بقطع 3400 من الفنيين
والموظفين الكتابيين وفقًا
لإحدى نقاباتها ، حيث قامت هيلتون بتسريح ما يقرب من
22 في المائة من موظفيها لأن
الفيروس يعيق السفر الترفيهي وسفر الشركات.
هذا
يعني بالطبع أننا نعلم أنه سيكون هناك
تأثير مضاعف على عدم وجود قروض عقارية
خاصة أننا نرى بعض الأرقام
حول نعم الأرقام الجديدة تمامًا من
ليلة سوداء تظهر أن تأخر سداد الرهن العقاري ارتفع
بنسبة 20 ٪ في مايو وهو أعلى مستوى منذ
2011 أنت '  لقد حصلنا على أربعة وثلاثة ملايين من
مالكي المنازل الآن إما بعد 30 يومًا من تاريخ استحقاقهم
أو أنهم في حالة حبس رهن نشط ،
أعتقد أن ما يظهر لك هو
الوباء بصراحة إنه يوضح مقدار
الضغط عليك ولا توجد ميزانيات شخصية
بصراحة تامة لذلك هناك الكثير من الناس في
هذه البرامج حيث لا يدفعون
قروضهم العقارية الملايين منهم لا
يدفعون قروضهم العقارية حتى نصل إلى
الجانب الآخر من الوباء